and new videos showing school officers
trying to restrain a student by his neck
after a fight
now parents are sharing their
frustration about this situation good
evening to you thank you for joining us
at six i'm bryan loftis and i'm denise
valdez it happened at palo verde high
school 8 news now reporter victoria saha
has been looking into this story for us
she joins us from the studio with more
on this incident victoria this is the
video sent to me from a parent according
to them this is the aftermath of a fight
that broke out during lunch on wednesday
you can see what looks like the clark
county school district police officer
having his arm around the side of the
student's neck this video comes as a
shock to the parent whose daughter
witnessed it all and brought it to our
attention
katrina singer says her daughter was
waiting in line at lunch when a fight
broke out wednesday at palo verde high
school a student was being restrained by
the ccsd police if you look closely the
student is laying on the ground facing
up an officer is on top of him with the
officer's arm around his neck when i see
a child on the ground in a choke hold by
an adult really is what i see although
it may look like a chokehold to the
average viewer we showed the video to a
former henderson and nypd officer david
colmer of course it doesn't look good
any videos where you have an office
obviously around the neck area it's a
sensitive time regards the policing
personally it looks like he's trying to
take the person into custody and that's
where he landed on the floor while they
were tussling around in general to me i
don't think there was any type of intent
that he's trying to really hurt the
student that's there chokeholds are
banned officers are allowed to use
what's called a lateral vascular neck
restraint in very limited circumstances
that's when either the life of the
officer or another person is in danger
it is not allowed if the person is being
assaulted dcsd said this was not an lvnr
and all ccsd procedures were followed
saying in a statement initial reports
indicate employees involved followed
procedures to calm and protect an
individual who is involved in an
altercation and who continue to
physically assault employees working to
de-escalate the situation but singer
says the video is still disturbing and
the officer could have done better i
don't see that the child is you know
fighting or resisting in this next video
you can see the student is in handcuffs
and walks away with the officer
it's important to note we don't yet know
what happened directly before that video
started the lieutenant of ccsd police
says he was not aware of this situation
until we brought it to his attention